Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question
d'Antoine qui me demande :
« J'ai déjà entendu parler d'Innus des villes et d'Innus des forêts. Y a-t-il une différence entre les communautés
d'une même nation? » Antoine, c'est une question
qui a quand même deux niveaux.
Le premier, c'est de dire qu'il y a
les Innus des villes et les Innus des forêts,
c'est comme dire qu'on appartient à un ou l'autre,
mais qu'on ne peut pas traverser
de l'un à l'autre. c'est souvent lié
à l'idée qu'on était obligé de rester dans
les réserves et que quand
on sortait des réserves,
hé bien, c'est qu'on était devenu des
Innus transformés. C'est-à-dire,
souvent à cause de la Loi sur les Indiens,
des Blancs aux yeux de la loi.
Donc, ça faisait en sorte que quand
tu étais un Innu des forêts ou un Innu
des réserves,
c'est que tu étais un vrai Innu,
et quand tu étais un Innu des villes,
tu étais un Innu transformé qui avait perdu
l'identité.
Ta deuxième question, c'est de dire
s'il y a beaucoup d'identités différentes au sein
d'une même nation, oui. Quand on parle d'un Innu,
par exemple, de Pessamit et un Innu d'Ekuanitshit,
tu vas avoir deux
cultures différentes. Pas parce que ce ne sont pas
des Innus, mais parce que
le territoire se transforme.
Même si tu vas au Lac-Saint-Jean,
je donne tout le temps cet exemple-là, les Innus
vont utiliser beaucoup le piquant de porc-épic
pour faire de l'artisanat.
Et si tu vas dans ma communauté à Ekuanitshit,
on va manger beaucoup plus la viande,
mais presque pas utiliser le piquant.
Donc ce sont des différences
liées au territoire, liées aux traditions.
Et même, il y a des différences au niveau
linguistique. Alors, quand on parle
de la situation géographique comme étant
quelque chose qui influence la culture, oui.
Mais c'est lié au territoire.
Mais quand on parle d'être en ville ou en forêt,
là c'est souvent lié à l'idéologie qu'on
devait rester dans le bois, sinon
on devenait des Blancs, alors qu'on le sait
aujourd'hui, que ce n'est pas vrai.
Il y a énormément de Premières Nations
qui se retrouvent dans les villes et ça
ne change rien dans leur identité en tant
que Première Nation ou en tant
qu'Autochtone. Donc j'espère, Antoine,
avoir pu répondre à ta question.
J'espère que vous n'hésiterez pas à nous
envoyer d'autres questions et à partager
ce vidéo. Je vous souhaite
une très belle semaine.